okay four people joining this live
stream we are talking about incremental
language development fourth language and
one of an infinite series of meetings
about this topic there we got several
different areas to discuss today let us
start our feature space plot option okay
so the issue here is we're doing a
something like a feature space plot and
I wonder whether there are um
and the question is when does it display
you know what I'm saying when does it
display when does it display the literal
objects as the things - okay and I can
see many cases where you might do this
right so if I do this for example this
is Bret here I assume back yes sir right
so let's talk about list plot an it's
analog of this alright this is okay so
here we've got lots of stuff you know in
this particular case it might be
perfectly reasonable to label only those
colors right but sometimes I want every
single every single one of these to be
indicated with its color swatch okay so
but is there an analogy if I want you to
have let's say I was just doing a list
plot okay and I want to have every let's
say I'm doing a list plot of where I
want the points to be random swatches
how would I do that I mean you could do
it with you know labeled wrapper you
could do it you know with an association
worth well it's true the labeled wrapper
so if I say labeled so I'll say
something like you know let's just do I
squared and then let's say random color
okay we claims
is going to fail where do you think
that's gonna fail okay that's not doing
what I want that's showing the points
and showing labels on them right and so
then this is you know if you add a third
argument to label and say that you want
it in the center which isn't well
documented then you guys will get what
you're looking for there's a documentary
at all center as an argument to labeled
is documented it's not documented for
list plots okay and it looks like do we
think labeled with Santa is the right
name I mean got a rapper I think there's
room for a different type of rapper you
know sort of a marked yeah sort of thing
yeah that is the analog to plot markers
because I can imagine somebody wanting
to make a geo plot with um you know with
a picture of the biggest cathedral in
each city or something on the city well
I mean not even that necessarily you
know so you plot a bunch of cities but
you want the capital to be a star or
yeah okay well how would you do the
thing where you plot you know mountains
with a picture of the mountain as the as
the mountain no it's how do you well
okay what does plot markers do so plot
markers would do this but here um what
can I do on the right hand side there
let's say open marker so that's gonna be
little circles why isn't there more
choice there about what to do because we
don't have that many presets sorts of
shapes right I mean so the downside with
plot markers is that
it works per dataset mm-hmm right no so
if you put each of those labels in its
own little list yeah yeah I understand
but no I mean I think your point about
the needing something like marked except
you don't like that term agreed
um okay call and our live streamis is
saying the inconsistent in labeled and
geo marker can be quite annoying what is
that so geo marker is um right right
that's the marker that says put it here
right on the in the geo case correct
which is something we don't have in this
case so that
I mean the analog the obvious analog
will be marker this is a little weird
because this would be this would more
naturally be geo marked except that's
very weird
um it's Jose here yes I'm just go ahead
I'm thinking geo marker takes the 2d
position it's a full position while for
this plot well you can give the full
position I mean I could perfectly well
say here I'm assuming that what I could
do here I could say you know I squared I
cubed or something here and um oops
I'm assuming this would work just fine
yeah yes but the previous situation in
which it was taking only the value it's
kind of different different I think it's
just assuming I mean geo marker just
doesn't happen to have an obvious one
parameter family right well I mean so so
geo Mercker has a default shape that it
once you use but it has the two argument
form that allows you to say what the
marker is exactly but that's exactly
analogous trips we did something like
marker here yes but would it work also
with list I squirt comma labeled or
marker I something but there's something
now this thing right I mean because this
one this geo mark up so let's be clear I
mean so so if we say um something like
well let's just do it
geo marker um well what can I say here I
could say um oh my gosh wouldn't earth
is that there's a very exotic creature
wow that was really weird I know what I
pressed on my keyboard that that's
interesting that's a some curry weird
control key that I pressed anyway
okay five tallest mountains in Europe
for example okay let's let's get rid of
the geo marker just so we know what
we're doing here um oh for goodness sake
I hate this way of having to resolve
this but anyway all right let's let's go
Anthony list of that okay great
Mount Elbrus is not in Europe is it wait
a minute this one bonkers didn't it
well anyway geo list plot is that the
disco bonkers doesn't know where Hollies
compare [ __ ] edgier range goes to all
over the world it might be very much to
the east oh wow the Alps lost out okay
um okay anyway not worrying about our
geography here but but let's imagine
then that on this so we want to say is
Geographics of geo marker of hash comma
hash take a listen
oh I see okay yes okay let's see how
beautiful or not this is okay so now I
have it too small but it works okay so
now what would happen if I wanted to
make those bigger there is an option of
Jamaica called scale during aspects of
geo marker that are awful yeah these are
really awful I mean those those are
those are grotesque string options okay
so this is a bit of a and what what what
scale could I give here the default I
think it's once or try to
there will be 1 units of what that's too
much is that across the the image or
something point 0.1 or something yeah
that's probably a cost the image so it's
probably in scaled coordinates right
well I mean that functionality is quite
nice but but um um okay actually this is
a complaint from Karl on the live stream
which i think is interesting um which is
the complaint that Geographics doesn't
take some of the other see that doesn't
take what what happened to legend did
here so I'm asking um no no this is the
issue that we are gonna have to kick our
way through that graphics doesn't take
annotations like legend did right there
are things that graphics doesn't know
about that you know more abstract
functions do better where should I store
this um Devon do you have a where should
I storing this you have a folder called
labeling which might be appropriate okay
there's also one called visualization
that's preservation cause I think it's
gonna be general okay um okay yeah this
should add to this discussion something
that we've been wanting for a long time
for future space plot is when the data
is labeled like in mesh learning like
let's say you take 1000 digital mists
that are labeled mm-hmm and we do
feature space plot of that what you want
is to have a legend an automatic legend
that appears and you know that let's say
it's speech point will be colored
according to to the color in the swatch
legend and there will be all the ones
that blew all the two are red this is a
very very classic user feature space
plot like in marketing pages we need to
do that a lot and currently we have to
result in this plot okay I don't know
how into that I don't think that fits
directly into this although I agree that
that's very useful functionality so
let's say we have like I don't know 30
of those and then what you're saying
right now is that and again this is
gonna go bonkers again I mean this is
going to be so what you would like to do
is to say feature space plot yeah that
just works and right what does that
doing right now it's use the labels as
labels okay it's not obviously stupid I
mean what let me ask the analogous
question if I do a list plot of
that too oops I don't remember which way
it goes around oh no I know it goes this
way around so that's using call-outs
right as opposed to I mean whereas here
what would happen if I wanted to make
these be call-outs in other words if I
wanted to have those things be the
actual raw you know
m-miss digits but have call-outs for the
labeling how would I do that
I'm you should be able to do it somehow
with labeling function but I don't
remember which way it maps for feature
space pod off the top of my head okay
let's unroll what were the issues are
here okay so one issue is you know what
is the analog of geo marker for ordinary
plots right that's one question another
question is you know when there is a
value and a label how to indicate that
and this is one example of how that's
indicated this is another example of how
that's indicated so I'm saying these are
defaults but the question is is there a
you know and presumably the labeling
function is an obvious way to do that
but maybe what we need are some you know
string names for the labeling function
that correspond to the things that are
useful see for example if this was I
mean if this I mean who knows if this is
right but let's say that this was
labeling function arrow call-out um
which I think that is what that is okay
well so then let's say laser just
labeled instead I think this is labeled
work
you see the hole okay yeah well that's
not very good right so we should try to
make that work but but it allows you to
see what the arguments to the labeling
function are and I agree labeled should
work all right so the first slot one is
the position slot two is sort of an
index into your data set into your data
and slot 3 is labels coming from
different areas well that's kind of
obscure yes okay so this needs to be
cleaned up by the way call on our live
stream is lamenting that call-out does
not work in Geographics now in call-out
doesn't work in graphics either right
why doesn't call-out work I mean okay
let's just let's just discuss this
because it's so obvious how this gut
this story has there's only one way that
it can end right okay so the issue is if
I do a call out of I I squared
you know I for example table 6 whatever
it is okay I have that and I say
graphics of that it's gonna be dumb as a
stone right okay this is wrong okay the
question is how do we fix it and that's
a completely different set of people and
we've discussed it probably in the last
six months and I don't remember exactly
what all the details were yeah I know
and it then everybody says it's
impossible what we're gonna do it anyway
right but I don't think it's a different
set of people because I think what's
going to happen is that there's
essentially an up value here that when
it sees there's a call out it's got to
go resolve that
well in any case let's let maybe we
should set up a separate meeting
specifically about this issue this is
something that may be easier in
Geographic stunning graphics because at
the moment it would be easier in
Geographics than graphics because
Geographics already has to do a lot of
processing right I mean to get this to
work in Geographics right I mean the
other thing is that really you don't
want to do that call back call out by
collabs
for sure you won't take the whole you
know the whole zoo here and just you
know do that once and for all right okay
but but let's come back here okay okay
first question what's the analog of Jim
okay actually the original problem was
how do we say okay so the next question
is when there are lots of things to
label how to indicate how many of them
to label right and I think my most
recent suggestion on that email thread
was that we used labeling function goes
to all to say you want everything
labeled yeah but I think I think we want
an option that just says you know max
labeled items or something right I mean
so the the fun thing is so we have an
option for this what is it it's a method
option and it's max labels goes to n but
it's not really max labels we just
didn't have a better name and so we went
with it even though it's not really
accurate right so if you take you know
colory thing yeah and you add method
goes to max labels goes to a thousand
that's going to take forever so I want
to do that um well let's
what would happen with a hundred does it
still do a hundred this is okay so the
set set max labels goes to fifty in that
case method arrow well that didn't work
well so the thing is is like I said it's
not you know an accurate name and so
what this option really is is what is
the number of labels below which I'm
gonna show everything and yeah so if
there's fewer than 50 it labels you know
it does you know no points no call-outs
just everything is a swatch if it's more
than 50 then it switches over to the
call-out and the automatic placement and
avoiding and whatever but it's not you
know actually you know in this case
there's still a hundred or these nearly
a hundred labels you know I think I see
two off the top of my head okay so
you're saying that okay what would
happen if I said um um okay so if I say
labeling function arrow none don't I
just get points okay okay okay so the
point is that we've got okay so you're
saying labeling function goes to all is
the thing that gives everything as a
swatch well I don't think that's crazy I
think that's a reasonable thing to do
but I still think we need more control
of what's happening
okay so let's agree that we're going to
do that labeling function arrow all
gives you give some you know swatches
everywhere um okay don't forget to
document it properly will do okay but
now this question about um okay so what
this is is the maximum number at which
you still guarantee to do only swatches
correct it's where you switch from
swatches it's the max number where you
switch to not doing swatches okay so
what effectively that is in a first
approximation it would be um I mean here
is a version labeling function arrow and
then it would say some kind of
conditional expression you know if you
had a count here of the number of
objects it would be saying if you know
hash greater than 50 none otherwise all
roughly right so in other words this
would be you know we could have a
labeling function thing which is a super
labeling function which is a labeling
switching function is that determines um
okay okay so what about max labeled
items no that's stupid cuz they're going
to be more well no it's the maximum
number of items that are explicitly
labeled and max labeled items could go
to a could either go to a number
um which would then have some default
behavior like this or it could go to a
function like this what if the labeling
function is a list the first is there to
function and the rest are parameters
like at this one there are like 40 or
something
Sandra on our live stream is very
reasonably saying shouldn't it take
account of the size of the labels yes
that's true I mean if these are giant
you know how do we take account of the
size of the labels you mean so that's
why it switches to the automatic thing
eventually right well we also need the
label size which is kind of cruddy in
the way that it's specified right now
right we don't even have that how do we
specify the size in an inner in this
case here how do i specify the size of
those labels
in that case oh where did that I mean
I'm not sure that we have a control in
that particular case because
those are you know that's the typeset
form of those individual colors right
you know so those are just you know
whatever you get when you do read and a
standalone thing okay so I'm gonna do
this that's good
why does it do that why is it that size
and that's observed ugly thing I mean
it's that size because I mean typically
you aren't just looking at as you know
single color right I mean you have your
pictures of mountains or something sure
I understand but I understand but how do
I control that size now there's a little
grip it's an option for this okay I
think it's clear like sighs okay which
is an option to labeled which is an
option to the visualization functions so
you specify it for list plot okay so
let's say point one you're gonna want
scale to point one if you do that and
why did it just do this silently well
any point one is a size it's one tenth
of a point right here so there's a whole
bunch of little tiny okay so let's say I
want twenty point okay it's reasonable
enough I mean it's a little funky that
it's okay so that's like a ten point
size label that's not unreasonable
that's pretty reasonable do we support
that same thing in geo Geographics No
I don't think Geographics has anything
at the moment that this would apply to
when we yeah all the your markup at the
same time right or all the Geo vector or
whatever right I mean I would argue that
labeled should allow a labeling size
option locally that's not a bad idea
I don't think it does as a Content size
um I don't know if that's respected in
vis why wouldn't it be okay so let's try
this so let's say content size that's
inside the labeled we go content size
arrow random into random real 40mm
that's a fun message the entrails just
fell out of the goat somehow whatever
okay um well okay it's about to fix yep
but that should just work
I can't see any reason why the any of
these options shouldn't be you know like
like for instance here I would have
thought I should be able to say
presumably labeled um in there I shall
be able to say framed arrow true frame
is a frame era true frame okay I worked
it's a little weird but it worked right
okay you're some of the baseline
alignment sorts of things necessarily
make as much sense perhaps not rounding
radius certainly makes sense
lovely okay so you just got a Content
size thing to make work yep good object
the others to see which ones
okay so labeling size so I think
labeling sighs I mean content size makes
sense as an option for geo marker as
well rather than your very weird scale
option Jose yes yes um okay but this
doesn't tell us the original thing we
were trying to deal with which is switch
over from um so if I do labeling size
here so let's say I'm doing this this
one let's say I do vicious space plot of
like say 30 and then I say labeling size
oh it's not going to do that because
they are labeling size arrow will here
let me I don't remember you know how
much I mean give it a shot no okay so
then I don't think that's obviously bad
but it doesn't do I mean that I I don't
think that's necessarily wrong okay we
didn't necessarily want to have text get
bigger than normal
you know sorts of things right no I
agree I don't think that's obviously
wrong okay so those why is this taking
forever okay it looks reasonable right
and I think it's even the case that's
you know if you increase the number of
elements that the labeling size shrinks
a little bit well is that desirable I
don't think so I think you tell it to do
something it should do that if you sorry
I mean the default labeling size oh I
see okay fine that that was good yeah
labeling size are automatic you're
saying does that right okay so the main
issue is up to what size so I think we
want this max labeled items that tells
us up to how many items we will give
labels as opposed to somehow dropping
the labels now the other possibility so
then there's a question of how big well
I mean the other the other possibility
is what fraction of the surface area can
be covered with labels right right which
would be something like max labeled area
but that that is in the category of very
obscure well ending and I don't know
that our frameworks are you know sort of
Cadoo suited to actually looking at
total coverage
[Music]
like okay fair enough but then then so
for right now max labeled items doesn't
seem like a stupid thing to have because
that that is analogous to max plot
points right so in other words here if I
did a feature space plot with even more
things than I would have max plot points
you know and then I would stop plotting
those points at some point like sound
this right hopefully that works
correctly I'm not sure I've ever tried
max plot points in future space plot
well probably the the the underlying
feature space thing might take too long
anyway okay but so max labeled items
seems not completely stupid to me and we
could presumably one day decorate that
with which labeling method to use well I
mean Suzu I'm not sure whether
we need the new option if we're just you
know still extending right hands you
know special right-hand sides of
labeling function i wouldn't extend the
labeling function right hand side I mean
I think all I think it's obscure because
I think the labeling function okay what
are the arguments that are given to the
labeling function so the first argument
is the coordinate of the element so to
problem function docks oh here we go
value index labels right okay so another
thing it could have as hash for is the
total number in principle either that or
you've got to have some kind of
association of something I don't know
how you would specify it where it's a
switchable labeling function yeah right
not obviously wrong to give it a fourth
argument that's the total number of
elements is list of relevant labels what
does list of relevant labels zero so for
example yeah I mean you may have labels
coming from labeled rappers or call-out
you may have it coming from chart labels
or plot labels association keys and so
it you know collects those into okay
here's my proposal okay is my proposal
that what we do is we say max labeled
items could actually be a list that says
um
blah blah it's kind of the wrong way
around
right but that you know I was thinking
similar things I mean it's not
particularly elegant but well the other
possibility is to have a function
you know what the issue is that labeling
function is called on every element
either where as if max labeled items had
a function that was called on I mean
where as I mean it's put on each element
right but if max labeled items was
called on every element it can decide
what to do I mean if it had a function
that was called on on the list of
elements then it can decide you know if
that list is super long etc Xander is
suggesting labeling method function
I don't think that really helps because
I think it's the alternative would be
okay it's a global switch based on the
number of items right that's what we're
looking for
it's a good but you know maxed labeled
items is at least reasonably easy to
understand oh but the other options in
geo marker by the way color and okay
this is bonkers global switch we could
integrate it with this you know the
problem and this that I was raising
there's a lot of repeated labels then it
makes it legend that's a bit of a
stretch no no why why are you making
that that negative sound Brett that
doesn't seem like such a bad idea having
it tightened through no I'm completely
fine with having it look at the labels
and realize that you know everything is
either A or B and switching to color and
creating a legend I don't think these
options are the rights because well the
question is look the question is
well that makes Sanders suggestion about
labeling method function not be as quite
silly but as silly because then that's a
function that is given the complete list
of data do we have any visualization
functions that are just given the
complete list of data to do things with
you mean options or options okay I meant
options yeah
I mean they're things like plot range
which clearly implicitly do that but do
we have a plot range function or
something but we don't have a plot range
function I think it's not obvious we
shouldn't or anything that's along those
lines is an argument to this function
yes like histogram takes a second
argument that can be a pure function
that computes the bins not totally
self-evident to me the plot range
function will be a stupid idea maybe it
is a stupid idea maybe maybe the right
answer that is you just compute it and
then you feed that as the option you
just say plot range function I mean why
I mean inarguably this type of thing
could be the same thing except that we
want to bank switch it right right say
okay
how to do this I mean the other thing
that I was thinking is the possibility
is that you don't say necessarily what
the numeric cut-offs are but you have
the ability to say what's the chain of
labeling approaches that you're going to
try sure right you know so you have
marked call-out tooltips a as a list and
it goes through and you know it tries to
directly mark as much as it can and when
that starts clause causing overlaps then
it switches to call-outs to get into you
know more corners of empty space and
whatnot and then when those start and
you know and then when those are
starting to overlap then it falls back
to tooltip
sure and then you aren't actually giving
cut-offs you're just you sort of as much
as possible optimally labeling things
well in that case the labeling function
could just be a list right
look the fact is we could do this in a
slightly hacky way okay if we have max
labeled items
well that's suggesting nomaks labeled
items but instead
you know the problem is if I say
labeling function arrow arrow but the
problem is I don't have a way to say
labeling function is just the swatch
right so assuming I had that yeah but if
I said labeling function is call out
then it will never go into override mode
right it'll never go if I say call out
it's gonna cover every one of these with
a call out true or not true no if you
color it as I think call out it still
has the ability to switch to tooltip I
know that's not that's not good enough I
mean that that's in other words that
shouldn't be the case if I say if I say
labeling function to call out then I
want labeling function to be call out I
don't want it to automatically switch
right so in that case it will be call
out or dropped
No
Oh a so call out even if you know things
end up overlapping yeah if I say
labeling function is call out that's
what I want
now what we could imagine doing is to
say labeling function arrow and then a
list of functions here listen better
what to do in different cases and then
we could decorate that some more how
would we indicate what's the best way to
indicate um what's the best way I mean
you know it's stuff like that
which reminds me a bit of what we're
going to do for webpage panels in our
sort of CSS imitation I mean cuz this is
like responsive design type stuff
because I can imagine oh boy I can
imagine it's gonna matter what the image
size is oh it's absolutely gonna mad no
matter what the image size is with the
labeling sizes yeah because that gets
factored into all right so then
collision code what what I'm saying is
there's a default and yeah I mean that's
so there's desert and I mean the thing
that is frustrating to me is when I say
labeling function I will call up that's
what I want okay
the obvious thing to do will be to have
a wrapper for labeling function that
describes or an option to the labeling
function itself how would we do this and
you know I wonder if we aren't almost
okay so what we're thinking this well
right you know so so how often is it
that one of labeling function goes to
one of the symbols isn't going to be
what you want you know all none call out
automatic tooltip right I'm wondering if
we're trying to come
with you know designed to encompass
everything where the solution is
actually to have simple settings that
are good except when they don't but I
agree if they if you know you can always
then set so long as you so long as it
respects what you tell it to do I think
it's okay right but don't start ignoring
if you say labeling function to call out
don't start saying no no I know better
right yeah I mean I think the other
thing is that you still have I'm pretty
sure that feature spaceflight still
supports rappers to some extent
you mean like label them things yeah so
you're claiming that if I do this I say
labeling function to false but I say
well let's say let's say I'm doing a
feature space plot um say random word
ten okay so that would normally be like
this some stupid thing okay um and now
you're saying if I say labeled
no that's not that's that's just
interpreting the whole label the animal
as a thing to feature space plot try
call out instead of labeled what does
the naked call out do what does it do
normally what does it do if I just say
call out nothing it just okay so this
worked is what your snake this what this
worked right I mean in you know the same
with the label because if you look the
alignments are sort of varying a bit
right you know it's not always you know
the label I mean actually labeled by
default on its own sticks the label
underneath I believe yeah okay fine yeah
you're right okay so that was nice okay
no so that's still so that gives you
your you know sort of override ability
as long as we document it anybody have
any idea right yes so so so we need the
marked rapper right now okay right now
we have geo marker do we not right
and we have plot markers right yes then
it's also image marker what does that do
for like image feature detection
labeling or highlighting yeah I mean the
problem is that the meaning of marker in
these cases is really well okay your
argument would be the self marker I
think that the idea that there's a
marker and it's default is to be a self
marker is kind of weird because a marker
tends to be something that isn't a self
marker if you understand what I'm saying
so I think we want a different name
for the sort of self representing thing
what would that be these things are a
bit like a variations of inset they are
so I think people get scared by inset
and they should yeah agreed
do you know how long it took Krista
implementing set it's like four years or
something no I mean yeah there's fun
stuff that goes on with inset in corner
cases and whatnot yeah and all the cases
where you can have inserts chains of
insects that would lead the plot to can
you know to not have a fixed point in
terms of what size it is right okay but
so here what are some names name I hate
to rekt labeled that's absolutely
horrible avatar
does that mean I mean I know what avatar
means but I mean it's like you always
representation for the thing you know
icon icon would be closer but we've
already got we've got icon data and
we've got the guys is not you're
completely unrelated it's not completely
unrelated I agree I mean look the issue
is if the name was marker okay actually
okay so the issue is normally okay so
normally it would be something like okay
so in in list plot what would it look
like it would be less plot of this and
that's got to say what the marker is
right so it would have to be that and
let's plot it will be great except that
we have all these you know we have the
precedent of one arc tool tip in the viz
functions oh we have a good present of
one our call-out don't be in there in
the case of wait a second we've got okay
fine so you're saying there's a one Arg
marker as well right yeah which is fine
for something like feature space plot or
one Arg marker would be fine because the
coordinate you know what is you know
it's like what not what you see is what
you get but what you have is what it is
it's coordinate you know what I'm saying
coordinate icing yes Amy
even you know potentially makes sense in
this plot right you know so let's plug
our curve range of 10 gives you 1 2 3 4
5 5 out there yes well this is sounding
pretty reasonable to me so I'm just
suggesting thumbnail which we already
have a meaning to the advantage of
calling it marker is we could is that
actually quite useful to be able to put
arbitrary stuff there and it's neither a
call-out nor a label it's just the thing
itself which is exactly what plot
markers does so I think this makes sense
I think it's a good idea okay so let's
let's so we the our remaining issue is
the Etienne question of legend Inge for
a lot of repeated values right now is it
possible to legend a feature space plot
right now it is probably a very you know
a relatively manual thing but I mean
sort of tied in with what's that Ian's
talking about I believe it's sort of
internally going from one data set to
and data sets in some way perhaps you
know in some of the cases well you're
saying no I don't understand this I mean
it doesn't legend it let me let me look
at how this works so if I say table
legend did random integer but it's true
the same at me that's right it's like a
different label yes
okay so now I say let's plot of this is
what's it gonna do nothing why didn't
that work I mean so the thing is that
the legend it knows that the legend
wouldn't be useful why isn't the legend
useful the legend is perfectly useful
here the legend has it doesn't know that
there's a lot of repeated values there
it absolutely does no but sorry you are
mapping over a number I'm not sure the
construction the input construction is
correct what do you mean
perhaps the input so the legend it is
being mapped on random integer which is
a number so what well I mean the thing
that lets plot knows is that you asked
for legends but although I'm sorry I'm
totally confused here it should be this
okay I see yes so what it failed to do
was to unionize so to speak why didn't
it unionize it seems like it should have
union I thought it will I thought that
was why you weren't getting a legend in
the first place is because it you know
everything was the same blue dot
well I don't know why it's all the same
blue dot question one well because
that's you didn't tell us to use any
other colors why would I have done I'm
asking it to legend so it knows I've you
know from the very fact that I'm saying
legend this it means it's throwing it
into legend ding bins and they should be
different colors maybe so the typical
case for legend did you know in the you
know visit functions is you've got
multiple data sets hmm you've got
multiple data set you've got multiple
data sets and like one of them is you
know or a handful of them are special
and you want to know exactly what they
are right I understand that
but I'm asking why why wouldn't this
work this seems useful to me and it
seems like it should promote these
things to different colors and union if
I want it promotes endures colors then
it's not gonna there's not gonna be in
the Union operation well there is if
it's no no it's unioning the zeroes all
the zeros are in the same bin because
they have the same legend
I see I'm saying Union with respect to
legends maybe although I think this is
very low on the priority list I don't
think this is a typical case that I've
ever seen anybody well okay so how would
you do a TENS case even if you were
doing it by hand I would do like say a
gatherer group by your based on the
labels and then okay hey by the way
another another comment on our live
stream from Ian is could we have an
option to allow overlaps often have a
small number of tolerable overlaps I
think we do allow some level of
overlapping don't we I mean so if you
look at your feature space plot that's
on the left there yeah yeah they're like
halfway up toward the right there's a
couple of purples that are overlapping
but I don't think we have presently an
option to control how that is you know a
tolerance or something for that
right well we you know we could start
off having that as a method option
because you must it must be somewhere
there must be a parameter right I think
it seems like a good thing to try and
then it seems like a risk all over you
know a reasonable method option
okay well so the remaining things we've
got a few other items and this is for
Devin to make sure we follow up on Geo
Marco needs to have it's crazy options
you know made sane right so we've got
content size is the thing for scale I
don't understand why alignment isn't an
actual ordinary option and the color I
just don't understand I mean if I'm not
sure why we weren't able to answer you
know inherit the color from outside
maybe Jose remembers know this preceded
my time um well I think I think this
looks crazy I mean I by the way I would
like to make the point that for some of
these things like marker seems to me
that if you just give a color there but
it's if you just gave a color it would
produce the color swatch is it so
similarly here in geo marker if you just
give the color it will produce the
marker shaped color swatch that seemed
reasonable the Merkur shaped color
swatch so in other words right now
you've got that marker that's the
default marker yes so I'm saying if you
say geo marker Rome comma green so I'm
saying so if you think you get a green
square I get a green square with a
little wingy thing on it
- I'm saying I mean well right now I get
a green alright well I guess that's okay
I mean gray but you do I mean it would
be nice to have a way of you know
putting something inside the pushpin as
a pushpin so to speak so in other words
you're saying if I do this but I then
say style of geo marker , green that
didn't work why didn't that work that
seems wrong what well I mean I think
that's you know it didn't work because
it has the color option right you know
so that's crazy
yeah that's what I was saying I don't I
couldn't remember why it wasn't able to
just inherit so fine so let's find that
out or maybe it was just that we wanted
it to be red instead of whatever the
defaults well the gun color is or
something what would it happen if you
have a graphics inside and then you say
green outside do we call or green the
whole graphics no I don't think so
no we just say I don't know whether
graphics represents a you know restart
the stack type thing or whether a styled
green outside the graphic could make the
default color of the graphic be green
probably not probably as soon as you
start a graphic it's not I mean I could
imagine something where you could
inherit a color from the outside of the
graphic I think it is possible to have a
graphic in sets inherit the color but
you have to explicitly opt into it and I
don't think it's documented anywhere oh
okay let's figure out that out and
figure out if we can document it I mean
it's probably something along the lines
of setting base style to a current value
sort of thing right
okay we have very few minutes here but I
would like to just take a look at some
of the other things that we have here
all right so I think this one we weren't
sure whether you were interested in the
graphic or the format of logging great I
am interested in okay I'm interested in
what is the symbolic form of an Apache
log
you
you
um yeah by the way Ian's on a live
stream is saying just allow or don't
allow um overlaps I don't think that
will work because as soon as you have
because we're trying to make a decision
about whether I think it's more
complicated than that I think that the I
mean it's like you know it's like an
electric repulsion algorithm of some
kind um anyway that's a come back to
this okay so did you understand what I'm
talking about so there's a you know can
we make an event series or something
like it there's boy a different topic
than what we expected and I I don't care
about the flame graphs as such I'm sure
they're straightforward to make given
that we have a representation of a you
know of things happening so to speak
get get what I'm saying we don't have a
good way I mean like like this thing
with entering functions exiting
functions and so on you know how their
budget looks look I mean Apache logs I
think are just you know something
happened I spit out a line of info
somebody's asking where my birthday is
go look it up on Wolfram Alpha you'll
find it's tomorrow the UM um and I'm
outrageously old but that's that we
already knew um okay sorry that we
you're asking about what the 400 Apache
logs is I mean I think they would
actually fit reasonably well into a data
set I'm not sure I mean I actually don't
remember what they are either but they I
think they just have a date they have a
timestamp hi yeah yeah okay
well I think some people who know about
what Apache logs looked like after a
pine on this dress I mean probably the
people who'd be well suited to that or
actually like the cloud folks or some of
them right all right I'll ask about this
in the very next meeting that I have um
if somebody could could um Devin could
you send this to Matt please yep okay in
the microscopic time that remains let's
just see is gonna be more complicated
discussion yeah this probably more
decide that we're not covering this yeah
this one is simple yeah this one is
important the idea is that we are trying
to imitate nest while list which has the
property that it returns the the last
element returned is the first one that
didn't obey the criteria it's a bit
weird but we just wanted to check with
you hover if the lost one returned is
the first failed criterion one yeah so
the first one we've gotten a Yaqui isn't
it I mean the because usually it's like
I don't want this right but that's how a
nest while so it's it's a bit like it's
a criteria for when to iterate no matter
what happens
or for example if the first element
already fails it returns the failed the
first element because we always returned
in the seat um say that again if you
saying if it fails the trade ever we
don't return analysts we return yeah we
always under the seat in fault list we
always sit on the seat for example in
fold we have to read on something so
unfold we have to return something in
fold list we could return just an empty
list but we document that fault is the
last element of fault list
well we haven't yet yet documented what
the last element of fold while is what
the what fold while is right but we have
the president's a strong presence of
Falls and a nest one ok so your point is
fold while can't just return an empty
you know can't let's just return a sorry
so to speak it has to return something
and that forces us to say that the thing
that's returned is the first thing that
failed the criterion yes and to me it's
even more important the fact that nest
while which is so close to fold while
already desta yeah okay fine all right
okay so then what's your point about
fold well list but it's gonna have to do
the same thing exactly yeah I just
wanted to make you aware of this
straight oh yes toile list a it's lost
element is the first failure case yes I
have this example there with the square
root I have to say
until would have been no well what's in
red when the first failing thing okay in
a while loop
what do you return and what is while
itself return well it's like do it's so
while I mean it's only doing a side
effect and so its first failure I see it
doesn't have it it doesn't return
anything right it just does what it does
right well we have the opposite occasion
take a while take a while will not
return the first failure it takes while
it's true and then it doesn't never
return the dead value so to speak
I never returns a failing value right so
take while can return an empty list but
next while it seems like check before
iterating this requires more discussion
yeah I wanted to propose something
similar to fold well something like
iterate while you get new things which
is interesting operation of the fixed
point it's a fixed point of the whole
list yeah if you want yeah it's
interesting
agree that that's an interesting idea I
mean I'm not sure that fold is the only
case where that's a you know iterate
until I mean if there's no state if the
function is pure so to speak then
obviously there's a point at which it
fix points so to speak and it's definite
point unless it contains random numbers
or something right right this is more
like I have some generators I want to
make sure I have generated all I can I
think that's a matter I think that's a
higher order function because I think
what what that should be taking is a
fold and nest or whatever just keep
going well some things like nest lists
will always keep adding something yeah i
suture saying so but there are plenty of
things well we should discuss it but my
immediate intuition is that this could
be something that has a you know as a
higher order function that takes
functions and keeps going until their
output doesn't change somehow I don't
know completely what I'm talking about
there all right we should wrap up here
for those who are curious I am actually
as my birthday event tomorrow I am going
to do a curious pair of rather than just
doing the same meetings I always do I'm
going to do a a curious pair of live
streamed events hopefully there'll be
some information about those on social
media um anyway I'm I'm looking forward
to doing that so we'll see what happens
um all right oh I think we should wrap
here thanks everyone
um and thanks to folks on the livestream
for their comments and off we go
see